a man Divine's breaks the internet the
32 year old actress sat down with paper
magazine and opened up about her turned
from the picture-perfect child star to
tabloid target that included a series of
run-ins with the law and a slew of
disturbing Twitter rants the former
child star said it all began when she
started using drugs quotes I started
smoking marijuana when I was 16 even
though everyone thought I was the good
girl I did smoke marijuana from that
point on she adds that she later started
using harder drugs it progressed Stu
doing Molly and ecstasy
I tried cocaine three times but I never
got high from cocaine I never liked it
it was never my drug of choice
however Bynes admits she did start quote
abusing adderall that's when she says
things began to spiral and in 2010 she
announced her decision to quit acting
after attending a screening of her last
film easy a can we please be friends
absolutely quote I saw it and I was
convinced that I should never be on
camera again and I officially retired on
Twitter which was you know also stupid
but you know I was high and I was like
you know what I am so over this so I
just did it but it was really foolish
and I see that now after retiring vine
says she had a lot of time on her hands
and would quote literally be stoned all
day long watching TV and tweeting while
she declined to get into specifics about
some of her more alarming and hurtful
tweets she did express her regrets quote
I'm really ashamed and embarrassed with
the things I said I can't turn back time
but if I could I would and I'm sorry to
whoever I hurt and whoever I lied about
because it truly eats away at me this is
the first time Bynes has opened up
publicly since her 2017 in her
with Hawley school but the public like
hasn't really seen you in five years and
I think your fans want to know how are
you doing I'm doing great thank you
really great and then amanda bynes
interview how did you land that I've
known her for years and she wanted to
come out to tell people that she was
okay she just wanted to show people that
she's alive and doing well I'm having
fun now Bynes tells the mag that she's
almost four years sober quote I don't
miss it because I really feel ashamed of
how those substances made me act it was
like an alien had literally invaded my
body Bynes says she plans to return to
acting quote with excitement and hope
for the best
adding what's there to lose I have no
fear of the future I've been through the
worst and came out the other end and
survived it so I just feel like it's
only up from here
you